It's almost a new year, and as it does every
month, Netflix is celebrating impending newness
with a slew of fresh releases.
From new hits to classic Scorsese mob films,
here are the releases you definitely won't
want to miss on Netflix in January 2021.
If you're someone who can't get enough of
Netflix's original movies, you'll be delighted
to hear that the streamer has a solid selection
of new projects set to kick off 2021.
Fans of fairy tales looking for a new take
on an old classic will definitely want to
check out Charming, an irreverent animated
flick that forces Prince Charming to seek
out his one true love, rather than the other
way around; the film drops on January 8.
Then, on January 15, you'll want to catch
Outside the Wire, which features Marvel Cinematic
Universe favorite Anthony Mackie and Damson
Idris as a droid officer and drone pilot that
team up in a futuristic military zone.
"We remove advanced weapons from beyond the
wire."
Together, the two must find a doomsday device
before it's too late.
On January 27, don't miss Penguin Bloom, which
stars Naomi Watts, Andrew Lincoln, and Jacki
Weaver as a family struck by tragedy.
Their lives are turned around by a tiny injured
bird named Penguin.
After buzzy December 2020 debuts like Shonda
Rhimes' period piece Bridgerton and new seasons
of Big Mouth and Chilling Adventures of Sabrina,
there aren't quite as many new shows dropping
in the new year.
However, the exciting news is that some beloved
favorites are returning for new installments.
At the top of the month, Netflix subscribers
can see Nicolas Cage share the interesting
and unexpected origins of the English language's
most... colorful words in History of Swear
Words, which arrives on the platform on January
5.
A bit later, Disenchantment fans can finally
see Part 3 of the medieval-fantasy-kingdom-set
animated series.
On January 21, the French comedy Call My Agent!,
which features Emily in Paris star Philippine
Leroy-Beaulieu, returns for its fourth season.
If you haven't checked out the sharp show-business
comedy, now's the time.
Though there's no release date just yet for
the highly anticipated third season of Cobra
Kai, the modern spin-off of the Karate Kid
story, fans can get excited: The new season
will hit the service sometime in January.
"Put one of those hashbrowns at the end, you
know like 'hashbrown team Cobra Kai' or something.
And then send it to the internet!"
If you want to revisit some classics and favorites
in January 2021, Netflix definitely has you
covered.
A huge group of movies hits the service on
New Year's Day, so you can start your year
off right on January 1 with everything from
Academy-Award-nominated flicks to gut-busting
comedies.
"Fo sho.
Fo sho.
I'm gettin' that fo sho."
A small selection of the January 1 drop includes
favorites like Steven Spielberg's Catch Me
If You Can, Martin Scorsese's Goodfellas and
The Departed, the feel-good biopic Julie & Julia,
Julia Roberts' beloved romantic comedy Mystic
Pizza, the first Robert Downey Jr.-led Sherlock
Holmes movie, both Sex and the City films,
and the raucous coming-of-age comedy Superbad
– to name just a few.
After that, a few more awesome movies will
join the Netflix ranks — including The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo, Spring Breakers, and
Hook, which hit the service on January 5,
January 10, and January 15, respectively.
As Netflix subscribers continue to hunker
down at home in January 2021, they certainly
won't be hurting for options whenever they
want a movie night.
Netflix is adding a handful of new and returning
non-original shows to the service in January
2021, but there's one big standout.
On January 15, the fifth and final season
of the buzzy Syfy series The Magicians – which,
with its focus on teenagers at a secret school
of magic, is sort of like a darker take on
Harry Potter — arrives on Netflix.
"Are we in trouble again?"
"Duh."
Pretty soon, fans of The Magicians will be
able to catch the latest season of their favorite
show.
If you're looking for hard-hitting documentaries
on Netflix in January 2021, the service has
you covered.
On January 1, learn how to make your everyday
life more efficient with The Minimalists:
Less Is Now.
A few days later, on January 6, you can check
out Surviving Death, a series about the possibility
of an afterlife, as well as Tony Parker: The
Final Shot, a look at the life and games of
French basketball star Tony Parker.
Pretend It's a City, writer Fran Lebowitz's
wry take on Manhattan, arrives on the service
on January 8.
"Now, everybody is looking at the phone, and
they've bequeathed the entire city to me.
They're basically saying, 'Fran, it's all
yours.
You know this.'"
On January 11, you can learn more about the
history of one of America's most infamous
illegal drugs in CRACK: Cocaine, Corruption,
& Conspiracy.
Two days after that doc's arrival on Netflix,
travel back to 1985 and learn about a real-life
manhunt in Night Stalker: The Hunt for a Serial
Killer.
Finally, on January 29, follow the Brooklyn
Saints football players and their crusade
to make the world a better place in the four-part
series We Are: The Brooklyn Saints.
As is the norm on Netflix, in order to make
room for all the stellar new films and shows
arriving to the digital library during any
given month, the streamer must do away with
a number of other flicks and series — even
ones that subscribers hold near and dear.
January 2021 marks the last chance for Netflix
subscribers to stream dozens of great titles
— including four seasons of The Tudors,
which leave on January 7.
2018's Mary Poppins Returns flies away from
Netflix via a magical umbrella on January
8.
The critically acclaimed drama Dallas Buyers
Club exits the streaming platform on January
15.
And the Daniel Radcliffe-starring black-comedy-drama
Swiss Army Man swims away on January 29.
A little before then, those who like to turn
to Netflix and use their laptops or TV screens
as a digital fireplace will be sad to hear
that a bundle of fake fireplace streams – Fireplace
4K: Classic Crackling Fireplace from Fireplace
for Your Home, Fireplace 4K: Crackling Birchwood
from Fireplace for Your Home, and Fireplace
for Your Home — will be gone from Netflix
on January 20.
Before the end of the month, be sure to load
up Death at a Funeral, Employee of the Month,
For Colored Girls, Mr. Deeds, and Pineapple
Express, as they're all leaving Netflix on
January 31, 2021.
"Think about a hermit crab, okay, and it's
a shell, it's like they go from one shell
to the next.
And that's what I am, it's like, I'm just
a hermit crab changing shells."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.